right now I'm standing in Bridge North
in the middle of England which is a
beautiful little town and I'm standing
outside the smallest house in England
that is currently occupied by my ex PA
how are you doing long time thank you
thank you to see you what happened how
did you end up being my PA and then
ended up being a full-time property
investor with all these houses including
the smallest house in the country so
obviously I just started off as yourp
comeing into all the crash courses I was
actually at the rent to rank crash
course and I was in interested in
property but didn't really know what to
do and you're in the back of the room
with your laptop hearing me talk about
rent to rents and stuff thinking damn I
could do that exactly anyway she quit
man she left me and became financially
free instead um so we'll talk more about
that in a minute but by the way this
area is banging how did you get this
deal what happened what's the story so
the story is the land lady was trying to
sell it what does she want for it 145
145 is not bad though is it really for a
house in this area you're right it's not
bad but the the Market's really suff so
so it's not it's it's a buyer Market at
the minute it is it is and this is
tiate I feel like a giant so is it
actually the smallest house in England I
believe so yeah really so they changed
the rules didn't they so oh about
building houses yeah yeah they did and
This falls under that I think the
smallest you can build a house is 37
square m and this is what this is
36 damn but this is like 200 years old
it is so obviously it's okay they were
trying to sell it for 145 couldn't sell
it and then what happened when they
realized they could sell it they tried
to rent it and you know what's really
interesting this is a crazy story
because you on my PA you've got this
house it's the smallest house in the
country M you remember my dad tried to
rent this yeah so my dad tried to rent
this hat wanted to rent it I found it
for him and then he was like nah man too
small he said he would he couldn't fit a
washing machine in the kitchen need to
duck and you can't where do you put your
washing machine there is no washing
machine they're staying nightly they can
wash their clothes when they get home
what you what about a dishwasher or
there's a
sink okay this is really small so they
were trying to rent it for how much £600
a month and they were trying to sell it
for 145 couldn't do either but you came
along and said you'll do both and then
in 4 years the plan is you'll buy it for
145 Y and you're going to save up the
money to buy it in the four years yeah
this is perfect you're paying £600 a
month for this you living here no no so
what who how are you making money who's
living here so we rent out Airbnb
booking.com and do nightly stays we
target contractors in the area people
that are just on holiday the great thing
about the area is it's Countryside there
is no good season in the summer Bad
season in the winter it's all year round
so how much do you make profit for this
on average in an average month I think
our worst month was £800 profit after we
paid the rent the fees the cleaning
everything
damn yeah oh I love this what a little
Jen I'm so proud of you a thank you well
done true story how long have I been
trying to come around this house and do
a little Vlog ever since I got the keys
right and I've not been able to because
been full they've been guests every
single day I mean there's guests here
right now there is a guest in right now
I had to message to see if we could come
she said I'll buy you lunch if you can
just let us come and film all right well
let's go upstairs yeah let's do it this
is it wow you've done it so nice though
did you have to like do it up did you
have to spend a lot of money
refurbishing it it was in really good
condition just a first month's run and
just little furnishings and I guess when
you've got a house this small like this
bed takes up the entire of the upstairs
so how much time does it take managing a
property like this cuz I know you've got
like a lot of houses so I probably spend
about 20 minutes a week and you manage
it yourself yeah completely manage it
myself well I manag it myself but I have
systems in place so I have cleaners come
in they have access to the system they
can see when people are checking in and
checking out that's the smart thing a
lot of people have cleaners but then
they have to micromanage the cleaners
but you've done it the proper way so the
cleaners have access to the calendar and
the calendar is all synchronized all
synchronized we have a key safe outside
so the guests can come whatever time
they want let themselves in they've got
the code so this is the shower I mean
thank God I lost a lot of weight because
I don't think I would have fit in this
shower this property I saw this I didn't
even think about doing this as a lease
option or service accommodation and I
think a lot of people would have turned
down this property this I bet this was
on for just weeks and weeks months and
months but you've come along and you've
taken an unwanted property one of the
smallest houses in the entire country
and you've turned it into like a little
gem so big up Leah a thank you up Leah
thank you I feel like for me it was all
about being educated this was open to
everybody but it got rejected by so many
people because they could see the
potential and even though I start off as
your PA I'm marrying your best friend
your best man at our wedding next year
yes it was still about investing for me
you've got to invest in the trainer and
you did that yeah 100% And I'd do it
again tomorrow biggest lesson from this
entire experience always look for the
opportunity as opposed to the problem
and never make excuses there's always a
way so this is the land lady who owns
the property what did you think when
Leah approached you and told you the
vision and she'd rent it from you
through a company and then rent it out
on Airbnb like what was your initial
reaction well let's give it a try see
how it goes which we have done and I
think it's a success in fact I'm sure it
is and the customers were absolutely
fantastic we've had some really amazing
people how has it been working with Leah
has she paid on time and has she been a
good um a good person to work with she's
actually brilliant because I can just
ring her up when there's any issues and
she's here she's within 5 minutes I can
I can just say okay what we're going to
do now and that's it it's sorted yeah so
I have no issues whatsoever it's
brilliant are you surprised with how
popular the house is with all these
guests coming in and wanting to stay on
Short Stay lets I was at first but then
when I look at the wedding venues that
are in Bridge North and around Bridge
North I can see the attraction for that
and people wanting to see the locality
and where we actually are situated and a
lot of people are worried about putting
their property on shorts tets about like
having big massive parties and stuff
you're not going to get a big massive
party in this house I guess but I think
one of the important things is I know
what Leah does is she would make them
give their ID and stuff up front uh vet
them when they come in take their car
details if there's any damages and
things like that have you had any
absolute Nightmare Horror Stories in the
house so far it's been a year or so
we've only had one in the whole time
wasn't that bad to be fair did Le deal
with them yes good she dealt with the
whole situation and she was here to
support me when we Haden to do the
clearing up so no no problems whatsoever
so there we have it such a tiny house
but this one property is basically
paying half of the average salary same
profit y boom Shaker another thing I
want to just add for that is in the
beginning I didn't believe in myself I
had no confidence once you see you teach
it and then once you start to do it it
just this isn't just my only property
this is just one of now I've got a six
figure business go girl all we because
of the crash course I'm so impressed
honestly if you want to come like Leah
did don't come and get a job and then
start n just come straight to the
property Investor's crash
course1 what would you say to someone
thinking about coming to the crash
course get on the website and book it
now stop thinking about it it's a pound
got nothing yeah I'll make it real easy
I'll leave a link in the description
okay and I'll make it1 come and meet me
honestly let's spend a day together
let's find you some hidden gems come
meet me link in BIO see you next time